[MUSIC PLAYING]
ROSE YAO: Hello, everyone.
Welcome My name is Rose Yao, and
I lead product for Google Maps
platform.
MIKE PEGG: And hi.
I'm Mike peg, and I lead the
Maps Developer Relations team.
So thanks everyone for joining
us here at IO this morning.
And for those of you
from all over the world
on the livestream
watching on YouTube,
either right now or maybe
later after IO, welcome.
So some of you know that we
need a Google Maps platform
announcement last week, and
we want to talk to you more
about that today.
Many of you are interested
in learning more about
how some of these changes will
impact your implementation.
And we hope this session
will help you to answer
some of those questions.
So let's get started.
First, back in April of 2005,
and before I joined Google,
I was amazed by what
developers were doing
with open data and Google Maps.
Here's the first
Google Maps mashup
created by Paul Rademacher.
Paul was looking for an
apartment in San Francisco,
and he was really
frustrated by needing
to go back and forth between
apartment listings and Google
Maps, which had just launched
only a few months earlier.
So Paul did it himself.
He matched up Craigslist housing
data and map tiles directly
from Google before
there was even an API.
So I personally
got really excited
about this, all the
creativity that was coming
from developers and designers.
And I decided to start a blog
that was devoted entirely
to this topic.
And I called it
Google Maps Mania.
This was my first post
in April 13th of 2005.
So for the next two
years, I would get up
every morning attempting
to chronicle everything
that developers were
doing with Google Maps.
And I formed some
lasting friendships
with a lot of the developers
from around the world
that were doing this.
So there was a lot of really
cool mashups and tools
being created.
And I think one of
my favorites was
tools that would let you
drill through the earth
and figure out where you would
end up if you went straight
through the earth.
There was a video
blogger named Ze Frank
who decided to make this
earth sandwich project.
And he made a tool with a
map on the left and the map
on the right.
And when you moved the map, you
could see if you centered it
where you'd end up.
And he challenged people
to place a piece of bread
on one side and the exact
opposing point on the Earth
to place a piece of bread, and
make the world's first earth
sandwich.
Super awesome.
So in June of 2006,
Google invited
me to speak at its first
ever developer event.
This is me at the Geo Developer
Day at the Googleplex,
and I'm really excited.
A few months later
my dream came true.
Google offered me a job, and
now here I am talking to you.
ROSE YAO: Continue your journey
in history a little bit.
Back in June of 2005, Brett
Taylor penned this blog post.
The world is now your
JavaScript enabled oyster.
Introducing the Google
Maps API to the world.
At that time, with the
help of Mike's blog,
Google saw all the
incredible things
that you guys were doing with
your data and Google Maps.
So we decided to create
an easier way for you
to build these awesome
tools and mashups.
I also joined Google in June
of 2005 in the APM program.
It stands for associate
product manager.
But in reality, it was a
warning label for engineers
that I really didn't know
what I was doing yet.
So it was a really amazing
time to join Google,
because we were
going beyond search
into products like Gmail,
video, and Google Maps.
My first job was on Gmail team.
But I have to admit, Maps was
always really near and dear
to my heart, because I literally
have no sense of directions.
I leave a store at the mall,
and I go the wrong direction
every single time, guys.
So Google Maps has been
a lifesaver for me.
So I'm really excited, 13 years
later, to stand in front of you
guys as someone who works
on Google Maps platform.
I think it's really amazing how
life has changed since Brett
penned that blog post.
First of all, we have more than
JavaScript enabled oysters.
We have iOS and Android
enabled oysters, too.
We have more than maps.
We have places, and routes,
and all sorts of products
that Google has launched
into this platform.
And I think the
key is our product
went from really simple
web-based use cases,
like store locators, to
powering billions of users
across multiple
industries like ride
sharing, real estate, travel,
gaming, and so much more.
Our expectations of
consumers have also changed.
Today, we really
expect technology
to help us with our daily
lives, like getting to work,
buying groceries,
or getting dinner.
Google Maps platform is the
foundation for this new wave
of products and services.
So I'm really, really excited
to be part of that journey,
to stand in front of you guys
today, to partner with you
developers to see how we can
build things to help people
as they move around the world.
We're constantly iterating
to deepen our understanding
of the real world, and to
bring those improvements
to our users, and to
you, our developers.
So let's talk about a
few of these things.
First, I want to emphasize,
on a daily basis,
we make over 25
million edits a day
to reflect the pace
the world is changing.
Your users are benefiting
from these same updates.
It's backed by
infrastructure that
serves billions of daily
requests to Google Maps.
And we serve more than 1 billion
users in over 200 countries
and territories.
To better serve
those users, we want
to make sure we speak
the local language.
So that's why we launched
support for 39 new languages
on Google Maps and Google
Maps platform this year.
We added support for languages
like Albanian, Danish,
Icelandic, Ukrainian,
Vietnamese, Zulu, and more,
because after all, what is a
local product or service if you
don't speak the local lingo?
And these languages are
spoken by more than 1.25
billion people worldwide.
So that means that the
applications you build
will also have that support.
You heard from
the IO keynote how
we're using AI and ML to
help users on Google Maps.
We're using the same technology
on the developer platform.
So for example, we know
that getting good address
and geocoding coverage globally
is really, really hard,
particularly in
countries like Brazil,
where buildings
change pretty often.
So this is a typical street
view imagery in Brazil.
This is a typical
apartment building.
And I don't know if you guys
have better eyes than I do.
Can you find the actual
address in this image?
It took me a little bit, too.
So the good news is we were able
to train a ML model to do this
better and faster
than I can, and that's
really what street numbers
look like in most parts of Sao
Paolo.
So using our machine learning
and vision technology,
we were able to add over 30
million geocodes to Brazil
this year.
Finally, we know that
details really matter.
So let's talk about a
few things that we've
done with both our Maps
and Directions API.
So two recent changes to Maps.
We made a number of
visual improvements
to our base Maps design.
The new style comes with
an updated color scheme
and topography to make it
really easier for users
to focus and read.
We also updated
the pinstyle mark
that marks points of
interest, so they really
pop on the map compared to
the previous circular icons.
The great news, you
don't need to do anything
to get this new map design.
It's already being served
to you through our APIs.
You can still customize
this using our styling APIs
so that it reflects your
use case, your brand,
and your details.
But you can also just
get this out of the box.
The other thing we did
was improve our render.
So the Web Maps API launched
eight years ago before tablets,
smartphones, touch
screens were widely used.
We just completed
an effort to revamp
the internals of
this client library,
allowing it to better
handle touch events
and take advantage
of modern browser
features such as
request animation frame
and enhanced GPS support
via well-changed CSS.
Tiles now load continuously
during touch gestures
such as pinch, zoom, or pin.
And no more unfilled gray
areas or over-zoomed tiles that
only refresh when you let go.
Markers and info windows
stay the same size
during these zoom animations.
They don't get
oddly small or big.
We know that the details
matter to you as much as they
do to us here at Google Maps.
So we want to think our
app developer community
for helping us test and
roll out this change.
As develpors, you guys
know how challenging it
is to get something this
universal to work right
for every browser
and every use case.
We couldn't have done
it without you guys.
And we really want to make
sure that this launch reach
the quality bar that
we set for ourselves.
So this has been our
experimental branch
for several months, and will
be coming to all developers
in the next couple weeks.
If you want to get
a head start or just
help us test new
features, you can always
change your version
number to 3.exp
so you always get the latest
and greatest from our JavaScript
APIs.
And I think the
greatest validation
doesn't come from me,
or anyone else on stage
who works at Google.
That comes from
you, our developers.
So thank you, Alex on GitHub,
for giving us this feedback.
This API has such
sweet, smooth zooming.
What else can we say?
All right, so you heard about
[INAUDIBLE] walking nav and AR
walking nav via the camera.
So you know that to make
that happen, we really
need to understand what the
world around us looks like,
and really understand
where sidewalks are,
and crosswalks are, and
how we can give people
great experiences as they're
walking through busy cities.
So we're excited to announce
the latest improvements
to our Directions API,
our HD Walking Directions.
So basically, we've improved
our understanding of the world
for walkers, particularly
sidewalk geometry
and pedestrian walkability.
And we're bringing that
improved model to our APIs.
In the last month, we've
been getting feedback
from our app developers.
In the next few weeks, we'll
be launching this to everyone.
If you're using
Walking Directions API,
no code changes needed.
You'll just get an
automatic upgrade.
MIKE PEGG: So Rose just talked
about some recent improvements
that we're making and
rolling out to you.
As we continue to make
these improvements
and look back at
the last 13 years,
we just want to thank you for
everything that you've done.
And the journey we've
been on together.
We're continuing
that journey today
as we introduce the
Google Maps platform.
It includes all the same
APIs that you know and love,
and a streamlined
developer experience,
new industry-specific solutions,
like our recent gaming
offering, and a smooth
path to scale as you grow.
We want your experience building
on the Google Maps platform
to be a more simplified
development experience
that's scalable to your
needs and easy to use.
To start, we're simplifying
our 18 individual APIs,
and putting them together
into three core products--
Maps, Routes, and Places.
These core products
work together
to provide the building
blocks you need to create
location-based applications.
Maps is a great set of
tools for visualizing
the world through maps,
satellite, and aerial imagery,
and street view.
Routes is optimized for figuring
out how to get from point A
to Z. Places is
perfect for answering
simple questions
around the world like,
what is this place or address?
And the good part is that
all these new updates
will work with your existing
code with very little changes
required.
Now let's talk about pricing.
We're simplifying
our pricing for you,
and moving from several
pricing plans to just one.
With this new pricing
plan, all developers
will receive the first
$200 of monthly usage
for free per registered account.
Most of our active
developers today
fall into this
free monthly tier.
To gain access to this
$200 of monthly usage free,
you just need to sign in and
set up an account on the Google
Cloud console.
And when you set up
billing for the first time,
you can also take
advantage of a $300 Google
Cloud Platform
free trial credit,
which you also can put
toward your Maps platform
monthly usage.
We've also done away with
annual upfront commitments,
termination fees, and usage
limits with this new pricing
plan, just to keep it
super simple for you.
Let's take a look at
some of the changes
we're making to help you to
optimize your monthly usage,
starting with Place
AutoComplete within the JS API.
So first, Place
AutoComplete returns
placed predictions for your app.
So it takes a text search
string from your user,
like restaurants or
museums, and then it
provides auto
complete functionality
as the user types.
So think of when you
type in Google Search
or in Google Maps how
that autocomplete works.
So in Place
AutoComplete, we're now
giving you the option for
session-based billing instead
of charging for the individual
characters a user would
type to find something.
That used to include
backspaces, even.
So this is done now
as a complete session.
And you also don't need
to worry about languages
that would have long names.
So this slide here shows the
on-page load configuration
steps you'd take.
You set up the map and you
create a session token.
Then once you have
that token, you'll
use it for all
requests in the session
through auto completion usage
and the final place details
lookup.
So next, we show how it looks
to hand that session token off
to our get details endpoint.
And then this will
supply information
about the places that are
returned from the autocomplete
get query predictions
as a total session.
So you can also end
a session easily
by generating a
new session token.
And you should do this when
your user very obviously starts
a new activity.
So here, place detail
with field masking
is applied to optimize the
efficiency of the queries
by only retrieving the
specific fields that you
want to return to your user.
So these are just a few
examples of optimizations
we're suggesting to increase
the overall efficiency
of your implementation.
We've prepared a full guide
of these optimization tips
that you can take
a look at as well.
So registered developers
of the Maps API
should have received an
email with the subject
line, important changes to
your Google Maps API account.
And that details all
the changes for you.
And if you're new to
Google Maps platform,
you can check out
this short link,
g.co/mapsplatform/pricing
to learn more about pricing
information there.
So we want the management
of your projects
to be really easy as well.
To make this happen, we're
using the Google Cloud Platform
console, which the Maps
platform is integrated in.
So when you're on
this console, you
can do things like
create projects.
You can manage,
track, and analyze
your API keys and usage.
You can even generate
billing usage reports
by exporting out
to Google BigQuery.
And you can easily access
new Google Cloud products,
since you're on the
cloud platform console.
So starting this week, all
Google Maps platform developers
will also receive
free customer support.
We want this to be a platform
that you can rely on no matter
what you're doing with it.
So we're offering 24-hour
support, seven days a week,
365 days a year.
And you can also access
that free customer support
from the console.
So how do we scale
all this for you?
What happens today when your
site or app becomes popular
is that there's a
manual effort that's
followed, which you have to do
to upgrade your pricing plan.
So with Google Maps
platform, if your product
grows beyond that $200
of free monthly usage,
we'll automatically update
you to the next pricing tier
without any action on your part.
And we'll apply
pricing discounts,
and let you scale easily
with less downtime
and potential performance
issues along the way.
You also scale quickly with
Google's global infrastructure
without having to think
about capacity, reliability,
or performance, no matter what
causes your service to peak.
Go-Jek is a really
great example of this.
They're one of Indonesia's
largest ride sharing
and delivery companies, with
over 30 million downloads
and 250,000 drivers
working for it.
And they're mostly on
motorbikes in Indonesia.
So they use Google Maps
platform in all components
of their service.
The passenger app
displays maps and allows
users to select a destination
using our Places API,
while address entry is handled
through the AutoComplete API
that I mentioned earlier.
The driver uses an app to
connect with the passengers,
and then the Directions
API provides the best route
and an accurate ETA time.
So there's actually
a lot going on
in the background with the
help of Google Cloud Platform
as well.
Go-Jek generates
about 4 terabytes
worth of events data
per day, and they
use GCP to enable
hundreds of thousands
of concurrent transactions.
One of the more
interesting use cases
is how they use Google BigQuery
through that data that's
being exploited to enable
better insights and faster data
discovery as a business.
We also know and care
about the unique needs
of nonprofits, crisis
responders, startups, and news
organizations.
So starting today, we're
significantly scaling our teams
to accept more applications
for these public programs.
We offer these programs
to provide support to you
in a number of ways,
including financial credits
that you can put toward
your monthly usage.
One great example of a
nonprofit currently taking
advantage of this program
and the monthly credits
is PulsePoint.
PulsePoint is an app
that crowdsources
where life-saving measures
are needed for cardiac arrest
victims.
PulePoint alerts
its app users who
are in walking distance of one
of these medical emergencies
that assistance is needed
right away, ensuring
that lifesaving
CPR can begin even
before an ambulance arrives.
Let's take a look
at this quick story.
MIKE PEGG: So it's in situations
like this where an accurate
understanding of the real
world and the ability
to connect people in times
of need are important.
These are the kinds of
nonprofits that Google Maps
platform is eager to support
through these public programs.
To learn how you might qualify
for one of these programs,
visit the FAQ section
of our pricing page.
So many of you
over the past week
have wondered how
this new pricing
will apply to your specific
Google Maps platform
implementation.
We've built the transition tool
to easily identify and merge
all of your projects together
into one view on the console,
and make monthly
use adjustments.
When we first launched the
Google Maps API, clear,
easy-to-understand
technical documentation
was at the center
of this for you.
We're keeping our focus on
this by making a detailed guide
available to dig
into all the changes
that we're making with
the Google Maps platform.
ROSE YAO: Thank you, Mike.
So Mike just spent a
lot of time talking
about the product changes and
our principles behind them--
simplified, scalable,
easy to use.
Those are things that we're
keeping in mind no matter
what we're building.
We also talked about
our core products--
Maps, Routes, and Places.
These three products make
up the building blocks
of any location-based
experience.
But I want to spend a little
bit more time today diving
into new category products
we've been building
called Industry Solutions.
Our first three offerings
in this category
are Asset Tracking, Ride
Sharing, and Gaming.
These represent when
we want to go deep
in an industry with a
strong location-based need,
and really work
with the developers
to understand how we can partner
with them beyond the basics.
So let's take a look
at a few examples.
We talked about ride sharing.
It's an industry that I think
we're all using the products.
We're all getting to work,
and dinner, and home, right?
And we realized that it was
growing really, really fast,
and understanding
of the real world
was critical to the industry,
and we wanted to partner
with developers in this space.
So when we talked to Lyft,
and Go-Jek, and Grab,
we realized there
was a lot of products
we could build together
that would make
a real difference in key
metrics like driver efficiency,
customer cancellation
rates, and honestly,
just how they run their
business and their product.
So let's talk about one
of the first features
we launched in this industry
and why it really matters.
An average ride
sharing driver has
to constantly switch between
the driver app and Google Maps
for directions.
In the time of the
app switch, they
could've missed the critical
turn, adding minutes
to the customer pickup,
especially in busy city
centers with one-way streets.
Those of you who live
in SF, you probably
know exactly what I mean.
Today, it takes about
three taps for a driver
to get from accepting
a new passenger to turn
by turn in Google Maps.
So when we talk to these
developers, we said,
what if we build an SDK
completely optimized for driver
efficiency, and provide
turn-by-turn directions
in the driver's app itself?
This is one of the first
features we've been rolling out
with ride sharing
partners like Lyft,
and it's really
just the beginning
of what we can do together.
The same thing happened
when we looked at gaming.
We started talking
to developers.
We asked them what they
wanted to build and why,
what tools they
used, and how they
wanted to run their
business, and what success
looks like to them.
So the result is a
highly-customizable 3D map
render based on our model, the
real world, built on Unity,
a platform we've never
supported before, but the most
popular platform for
mobile game development,
and a custom API to
answer a question,
where can you play
games in the world?
Now, this may seem
like a simple question,
but let's talk about why it's
a little more complicated
than it sounds.
So let's say you're
figuring out how to do
a really fun scavenger hunt.
That sounds doable.
OK, but how do you pick
the best points in Delhi?
And then you also have players
in other parts of the world,
let's say Sydney.
How do you make sure
that they always
find the best most prominent
places to find the treasure,
to hunt the dragon,
to do whatever you
want them to do in that game?
Sao Paulo is another
example where we just
talked earlier about
how hard it is to find
great POIs in that city.
So you can imagine scaling
this globally, because you want
your game to be played
by everyone in the world,
becomes a really hard problem.
And this is one of
the core problems
that the playable locations
API is designed to solve.
So I'm talking a lot.
Let's just see a game in action.
In this case, let's
catch some ghosts.
Can we turn the sound up?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC - RAY PARKER JR.,
"GHOSTBUSTERS"]
OK, who doesn't love this music?
- Ghostbusters!
[END PLAYBACK]
ROSE YAO: So coming
soon to a phone near you
will be Ghostbusters game
built on Google Maps platform.
And now I'm just going to
go hand it back to Mike.
MIKE PEGG: OK, so you've
just heard about the ways
that we want the Google Maps
platform to be simplified,
scalable, and easy to use.
And Rose has given
you a sneak peek
into what's ahead, whether
industry solutions including
gaming and ride sharing we want
you to know that we're making
a new commitment to you to
invest in this platform to make
it ready to serve your needs.
If you're new to our tools
or an existing developer,
visit g.co/mapsplatform
to get started.
So if you have any
questions today
or want to discuss new things
you'd like to see us build,
please come by our office hours
session later today here at IO.
And tomorrow, we're
going to take a deep dive
into how we built our gaming
product, which Rose just
gave a short preview of.
This will be a chance
not just to understand
the product, but also the
process for partnering
with developers on the
Google Maps platform.
The gaming session tomorrow
will be at 10:30 AM.
For those of you that
are watching on YouTube,
look for the topics labeled
build real-world games
with Google Maps.
And thanks everyone for
spending time with us
today to learn more about
Google Maps platform.
Thank you.
ROSE YAO: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]